what's the thing you think is overlooked
the most by creators who obviously
they're just DIY which there's
absolutely nothing wrong with that I'm
DIY but something that we're just
missing that is kind of a fundamental to
screenplays or screenwriting that could
be easily fixed
whether it's tech whether it's camera
stuff whether it's writing what do you
think something that like you
consistently think I have an edge
because I know this that's a good
question I think a willingness to tread
untraveled ground when I do videos where
I try and highlight small creators and I
and I ask people to give me
recommendations it's usually like kids
trying to promote their fort night
gameplay channel or it's somebody trying
to be the second-rate version of a
different creator and I think that's
born out of a few things but ultimately
I think the biggest reason is because
that's proven ground and you see that
somebody out there is having success
covering a certain subject or a certain
topic or a certain type of video and so
people think I'm going to do that myself
and as a result of that you have a bunch
of people poorly imitating someone who's
already doing it way better than anybody
else and it takes a little bit of
courage to try something that hasn't
been done before or experiment or go
outside the established wheelhouse but I
think that there are benefits to be had
and if you're gonna you're gonna create
stuff why not why not try and create
something that somebody else isn't
already doing
I think this point is like absolutely
huge no millionaire has ever become a
millionaire by reading someone else's
how I became a millionaire look yeah
because that's outdated information yeah
you know and they took advantage of a
narc adopted it's survivor bias yeah
you've got your god bless people like I
don't want to name any names because I
don't want to start any beast but you've
got these creators who are like hey look
just do this that and give it your all
and it'll be great and it's like well
there were a ton of factors right it
caused you to be the success that you
are that we're way out of your control
and once they're - it's so much less
interesting yeah when like Casey nice
that did his little vlog thing other be
blood den vlogs he kind of
revolutionized it in a way yeah and then
you saw everyone carrying around the
same gorilla tribe pet pod you're the
same set up you know and they're doing
the same like jump cuts and if it's if
it's I mean it's not that you can't do
the vlog a different way you can but
everyone is doing it the same way a lot
of people are and I think that's huge I
think realizing that they didn't find
success by that formula they found that
success by finding a formula that was
different
mm-hmm and that if you're copying it
you're no longer different you're no
longer you no longer have the thing that
they had that made them successful which
was they were the first well one of the
reasons why he's been so successful is
because what he does on the day-to-day
is specifically conducive to that blog
format and not everybody has an
extravagant to life as he does and
why would you I don't want to be
critical when I say this but why would
you want to be a second-rate kc nice tat
when you could be the first-rate version
of yourself so it makes sense
maybe you think the second rape version
of Casey well I mean if I want it yeah
if you want to be if you think the
second-rate version of Casey nights that
is way better than the first straight
version of yourself then now get to get
to know yourself a little bit better I
mean go go like so if I had started
doing YouTube two years ago or three
years ago let me rephrase that if I had
tried if I given myself from three years
ago the job that I have right now with
YouTube I would have washed out on week
one because a lot of what I'm able to do
right now I had to learn through failure
for those three years in order to be
able to handle the responsibility that
comes with creating this stuff that I
create and you you shouldn't want to you
say let me restart this you shouldn't
want to I understand that imitation is
the sincerest form of flattery and
everybody pays homage in some way shape
or form
there are creators that I lift things
from every now and then because they've
been influenced to me but you've got to
create something that it is that comes
from you and if you're putting on a
facade we're trying to be like somebody
else buying all the same equipment
buying all the same toys that they play
with having the same style of editing
using the same font that they use and
the same type of cuts and people people
don't want to watch a guy play direct
play dress up as Casey nice that like
it's like do that like hey what other
successful youtuber is doing like it's
just I don't you wouldn't create like
all these TV shows you see on on TV
people stolen TV well you wouldn't
create a knockoff you might well look if
somebody can create a knockoff Harry
Potter but it's not gonna be Harry
Potter right they're just gonna go watch
Harry Potter yeah and you would to like
I don't know right
no it's thinking out loud and again you
know sometimes I feel like a hypocrite
when I say things like that because
there are times where when I create
stuff I'm influenced by things that I
watch oh you've got a big forgiveness to
whoever you gotta beg forgiveness to for
that but at the same time you've got to
be aiming towards your you know your
unique perspective
[Music]